All right. Hi, everyone. I'm Shanta Uwali. I'm
a director of product management at Lambda
Test, and I'm really
excited here to talk about scaling automation
with KNEI and hyper-execute.
Now before we begin,
what I do want to talk about are the problems with
testing strategies today.
While all of us do understand that there
are many problems, but a few of
them that I do want to highlight are a
fragmented oversight, there are disconnected
testing processes which do lead to blind
spots, and there's a lack of centralized
governance which causes misalignment.
Second one being there are inconsistent
testing standards. Which brings variability
across teams
which actually just goes ahead and weakens quality
causes delays and erodes
customer trust if something is shipped out, which is
not exactly how it was supposed to be shipped out.
And finally, a big, big problem that
is still out there is brittle
unscalable infrastructure.
Now legacy systems cannot meet
modern testing needs, and at the
end they are slowing down innovation.
Now, if we dig a little deeper into
it as to why testing is breaking
right now,
we'll be able to find that
most of the times that we imagine that the
quality engineers or any developer team
focusing on testing would be spending on is
not actually being done.
The test planning and authoring, it's just the tip
of the iceberg. What we actually
see is
most of the time is actually spent
in fixing broken and flaky tests.
A lot of the time is actually spent in test optimization,
test execution and monitoring.
And finally, even right now in today's world,
a lot of the time is going into triaging
and debugging the tests.
Now we all know that Gen AI
is reshaping engineering in today's world, and
over the last couple of years what we've
seen is there has been a huge
code volume surge and what we
see here is that those code volume
surge will also need to be tested. So
the question to ask here is, is
testing ready for it or not?
Now that's where
lambda test comes in with modern intent
driven testing workflow.
Essentially what we're doing with KNAI
and hyper execute at the center of it all
is that we can allow you to plan
your test, author your tests, leveraging KNAI,
and of course go ahead and execute
them as well,
uh, by leveraging hyper-execute and give you
all the analysis as well
now. The major
question that all of you might be asking as well is
that is it only functional testing?
The answer to that is no. It can be functional
testing, it can be API testing, it will be
accessibility, visual regression,
performance testing,
because that's how you'll be able to meet your modern testing
needs. Now the way it will work
and the way it works right now is that
you can input any, any
requirement that you might have, which could be
via media or video and audio
file. It could be a
complete PRE document that you have that you wanna upload
or it could be requirements coming in directly from
Jira stories as well
that goes into KNAI
and KNAI gets all the context
and a memory added to it and gives
out relevant test cases to you.
Now those test cases, while having human
in the loop,
then are authored autonomously
by KAI agents and at
the. And all of that can be executed
on hyper execute platform.
Now the output that I'm talking about,
it's actually open source framework and language
leveraging selenium, Playwright, APM,
all of that to you and
going ahead and executing and giving you all
the analysis and RCAs that might be
helpful for you to figure out what's the best court coverage
and for you to be able to finally achieve
that in sprint automation that everybody
would like to do that.
And of course all of that
very seamlessly goes back and plugs
in your Jira workflows by
having that connection and more than 100 integrations
already being in place.
Now one great part of it is that
all of this works on intent. It's
completely natural language based which
allows you to move at light scale and
much, much faster as well.
Now what I would like to do is actually
show it all to you in action.
And uh
we're just gonna go ahead
and switch to a demo mode.
Now what we have here is a
Jira story, uh, and I've taken an example
of Airbnb right here.
Uh, this would be something that a lot of us
might get right
as when we're developing any, any feature
or any requirements that might have come from the
product team.
Once we have those details available,
what KAI
can do is that we can just go ahead
and add a comment such as lambda
test AI cloud,
let's say generate test scenarios for
me. And
as soon as I enter that,
Kenny and I will quickly analyze the description,
the summary, and any other custom
field that you might want, and within a few seconds
it will come back to us with a
response that,
great, hey, I have gone through the entire
context that you have provided, and I'm
starting to generate the relevant test scenarios
that you want. And if you just go ahead and click on that
link. We'll see, uh,
that all the information that was initially provided
to us has been figured out by KNAI and it
has started generating test scenarios
and multiple test cases within them as well,
giving you all the relevant information
whether the test case is a must-have,
whether the scenarios that have been generated are
the positive scenarios, negative scenarios,
edge cases, so essentially. Something
that you would have spent a couple of days going
through figuring out what are the scenarios and
test cases you want to automate.
KI helps you do that in seconds with
all the relevant context of your
application. Now one great thing that I also want to talk
about is that if you have existing test
cases, it also checks for deduplication
and does not create duplicate tests every
single time.
It saves a lot of your time by ensuring
that it has existing test cases in context
as well.
Now, what we can do is we can
actually quickly go ahead and see what details
have been created, and these are complete
information that would be relevant for you to
have your test cases ready.
Including test steps, outcomes,
and of course
we have added the flow in a manner
that we can have human in the loop.
Anyone can ensure that they are able to review it,
make edits to it,
uh, make any changes to the test steps as
well, and go ahead and review those
quickly and once all of them do make sense.
The goal is not to just be able to
go ahead and create these test cases.
The goal is to be able to automate them
in a singular flow itself.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna just select
a few of the test cases
and I'm gonna go ahead and create an automate.
Now the beauty of it all is that.
You, it's completely platform
agnostic whether you have a web
application, whether you have a mobile native application
or a hybrid application,
or whether it's just a mobile browser app that you wanna
go ahead and test.
You can choose any of these,
upload your relevant apps, whether it's
APKs, IPAs, provide us the
URL, even if it's a local
application that you wanna go ahead and test out, you can go ahead and
do that as well. And finally, just let's
say I input the
application under the test, which would be.
Airbnb.com, in my case.
And
let me just choose a few agents and
go ahead and create an automate.
Now as soon as I do that, KEI
will spin up multiple agents in the
background to autonomously author these test cases,
and we can see all of them are coming up right now,
right here.
So what we see is that multiple
test cases got authored and
they. Anonymously ran within the session
and the output that we get at the
end is something such as this
that they are providing you the
entire context, the entire test cases
at every and every, every
information which might be relevant to you.
So for example, it actually went ahead
and searched for an accommodation,
uh, figured out every step, and all
of this is intent natural language
driven. Now why I'm highlighting
this again and again, why intent driven
is necessary
because the problems that we were talking about initially
when we started out
being flaky tests, flaky locators,
triaging and debugging, all of that
comes into context when you have
that information available to you, and that
information comes as intent to
the system.
Now what you can see here is
complete details along with screenshots which might
be relevant to you highlighting what
exactly is
KEI doing where it's going ahead and performing
the test for you
and as an output what you also
get uh is the. Complete
code of it as well that you get a complete open
source code whether it's selenium uh
whether it's Playwright, Cyprus
WebDriver IO
you can choose
any open source framework and language which
might be relevant to you
and your team might be more comfortable
with that
and then.
Another thing that I do want to highlight, as I was mentioning
earlier, it's not just about
functional test. You can go ahead and have your
API testing, curl commands, assertions
on nest adjacent values, and
all the best practices that are already out
there from, from decades of experiences
that people have had in testing strategies
can actually be leveraged right
here itself.
Now, What
I also want to show you, which is really, really brilliant,
is that while authoring the test case,
Kenney and I actually figured out that there are
a few issues that are already there
within the system.
So for example, if I just open one of them.
What it was expecting was that
the map
should be present and enabled above the listing.
However, if you just open the screenshot quickly,
what we see is the map is actually besides
the listing uh that we see here.
So it has gone ahead,
suggested as a bug that the actual
outcome was that the map is present but it's
not. above the listings page now
that is something which only an AI will be
able to figure out quickly and give you that
result. Now the best part here is
that you can directly confirm and
raise a bug
on Jira and give it to your
relevant developers and team members to
have an extremely easy smooth flow,
uh, within the same system.
And of course you can manage your entire test
cases, all the details which might be relevant
to you now
what we've done until now is just
seen how multiple test cases are
authored and automated, right? We
have automation scripts ready for them,
but that's not all. That's not what we wanna do.
We want to go ahead and
bulk them out, maybe create a test suit,
maybe create a regression, a sanity suit,
and finally integrate them into CI pipelines
as well because that's how,
that's how development works for us.
So what you can do is
club all of the test cases together
into something called as test runs
and if I just open one of the test runs
that I've already run very recently, just a
few hours ago,
we'll see that we get complete
results, uh,
and
all the analysis that might be required for us
so we do see that it has a 70. 3%
pass rate, the total duration it took,
and finally what we give out to you
in case of failures is whether it was a new
kind of failure that has come up now,
whether it's an anomaly in terms of test execution
time, maybe a network call was taking much
longer than it was expecting to take,
or maybe it's a test which is always
failing, which might
need, need some help.
And if we just click on what the issue was,
we actually see a complete RCA,
a root cause analysis for
how many times the error has been repeated, what
is the overall error trends,
what exactly failed right there, and
if needed, any remediation strategies
that might be required.
Now all of this comes in from hyper-execute
by analyzing all your historical data
as well and any executions that you might
have. Now the great part here is
that you can also schedule your
test runs apart from integrating
these TOCI pipelines as well.
So in case you want to just go ahead and have
a sanity run every single day, every morning at
9 o'clock, you can go ahead and schedule
that. And
once you come back to any results, what you'll
also see, uh, is a complete
report if I just switch to this report section
of the historical runs that have happened. So
if you see, uh, these are a few runs that are
scheduled and are happening recently, we can see.
That what is the overall stability of
my suit, whether it's running consistently
or not, whether there's any decline,
uh, what is the pass fail rate overall
that it has been running over a period of time,
and what are the failure categories, whether it's
failing at a particular step,
uh, whether it's automation, whether it,
it is a product issue or whether it's an environment
issue because that's a huge problem when we're trying
to debug as to what is going on
and what might the concerns be.
And what I do want to show you is
that if we go ahead into any
of the details, let's say something did
fail, and
this is not enough information for us, we want to dig
deep, we want to see more.
We can just click on any of
uh the test cases that we see right here and
be navigated to a complete details for
you along with a video
uh along with all the command logs all the
uh relevant information that you might
need in order to debug the test
including the network calls and
an accessibility report as well.
Now this is something which is extremely
critical as of right now because accessibility.
Is something that everybody is focusing on
and needs to focus on right now so
you can get your full fledged report using
any specific WCAC version,
figure out what if there are any critical issues or
serious concerns that you need to get fixed quickly
and see a full fledged report as well.
And of course if you're talking
about mobile devices,
real devices, you get a complete app performance
report as well
for your performance testing whether you want to figure out a
cold startup time, hot startup time,
check how your application is performing
over a period of test session, whether
it's a peak in CPU usage,
whether your application is actually degrading
the performance of the device, and eventually
giving you slow results on a real device
because that's something that you cannot find on simulator remotely
orders directly.
Memory usage, disk usage, and all of that
information which might be relevant to you.
All right.
So I know that we've gone through a
lot of, uh, information,
but. What I do want to highlight
and just quickly recap is that
Lambda test is helping us
provide modern intent driven testing
and the only way we can move forward is
by ensuring that we're able to
capture
issues much, much faster and hence
release faster as well.
Now Lambda test has flexible deployment models
on AWS and we're listed
on AWS Marketplace as well,
and I really wanna thank all of you
for attending this session.
Uh, and, uh,
we are available at booth 679,
and if you have any questions, I'd be happy to help
out and if you want a customized demo we
can try out your applications directly on
KNEI as well and see how that works
out for you.
Thank you so much, everyone.